middle-aged white Americans are seeing
increasing death rates which are
confusing researchers why is this
happening we see that while non-whites
and younger people and people in other
countries are seeing falling death rates
a new study shows that the opposite is
happening for white men and women in the
United States aged 45 to 54 what are the
factors that researchers have connected
to these rising death rates for white
adults in the United States
number one suicide a study shows that
white middle-aged men and women are
committing suicide at unrivaled rates
this connects to the mental health
crisis in the United States but the
question still remains
why are whites more likely to commit
suicide than other demographic groups
there's really no simple answer
researchers say it has a lot to do with
culture they say quote it is striking
that suicide rates are highest in white
females and white males this is a
complicated social and cultural
phenomenon it has to do with a mix of
risk factors they say this is not an
urban african-american issue as much as
it is a poor rural white male issue
culture comes into play a culture of not
treating depression comes into play the
rural culture if it's not broken don't
fix it very interesting also a factor
drug and alcohol abuse prescriptions for
opioid drugs for pain control have
increased significantly since 1990 and
white people are exponentially more
likely to be on those drugs the New York
Times reports that 90% of people who
tried heroin in the last decade were
white heroin often comes after being
prescribed some kind of opioid
painkiller by a doctor that's another
factor and then the general decline in
mental and physical health middle-aged
white people reported problems with
walking a quarter of a mile climbing
just ten stair steps standing or sitting
for two hours even shopping and
socializing were difficult physically
and those are huge risk factors for
suicide
if physically you can't socialize that
is a risk factor and the lack of
socialization can make me more likely to
commit suicide so it all makes absolute
sense and lastly another risk factor
financial stress financial insecurity
weighs heavily on US workers and it is
disproportionately affecting those
without university degrees often rural
white middle aged people in Middle
America so this is a real problem and
the the takeaway here is very clear this
is a suicide crisis that we're having
and we need to connect suicide to the
lack of access to mental health and the
stigma around mental health the problems
with wages and the problems with access
to health care even for those who are
cognizant of the reality that depression
and anxiety should be treated by mental
health professionals even if you can get
past the stigma the cost and access to
mental health services is also a factor
and this is all connected to life
expectancy so when we say hey listen
let's let the for-profit insurance
employer connected status quo remain
because of business reasons well you
could make that argument but that's not
a very ethical argument when you see how
it directly correlates to increased
death rates for many groups this
particular study focusing on middle-aged
white men and women very disturbing
stuff and we need to not forget this in
the context of discussions about
healthcare as we proceed after the break
I will interview cosmologists Lawrence
Krauss one of our favorite guests on the
show how can we think about what there
was before there was a universe he joins
me next